and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a our tonight's review I'm man
oh my god this is the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
hi I'm iron boilers Pierce's guy code
Tony Stark
also known as Iron Man though we don't
think he's iron anything in his leg and
he all jacked up a jillion dollars but
gets really sad because somebody tries
to take out his chubby bodyguard so
Stark is like why did they try to kill
you chubby bodyguard probably because I
wasted Mickey work in Iron Man 2
so Tony Stark vows revenge I'll show
them he says I'm gonna tell them exactly
where I live
interesting strategy but his love
interest mrs. Potts is like don't you
think you thought this all more clearly
quits gonna happen tears are gonna come
to blow me up I should have thought this
out we're clearly the smartest person in
the world makes probably the dumbest
decision on the planet with absolutely
no backup planet on seriously who would
do that Tony Stark finds a little kid
hey mister you all right oh I'm having a
panic attack why are you in the dam
because I have a fear of losing mrs.
Potts and she is the world to me oh is
that why you constantly blow her off
Willa and gave terrorists eeeh try
somewhere you both lame like that had
bid the brightest and it didn't even
greet her at the door but instead had
your robot double do it so you could get
more work done it was kind of douchey
I'm not gonna die instead of protecting
her now you're going out to seek revenge
never ever learning from your mistakes
and constantly putting her in danger
have I mentioned I'm a superhero what do
they call you panic attack me hey these
panic attacks will work their way to the
plot now they won't think I hate you so
Tony Stark is trying to find this
terrorist played by evil Gandhi and evil
Gandhi is like what about Renaldo Tara's
I've actually an actor well if you're
not the bad guy who wins that one guy
who started to have a career and then he
disappeared and now he's trying to have
a career again okay Pierce bingo where
is he now kidnapping the girlfriend you
swore to protect damn it I should have
been played by Dudley ball so it turns
out guy Pierce is the guy behind all the
evil badness and he's like I'm not
really a terrorist I just developed this
new sheet thingy that will grow limbs
out and Platts is like yeah but people
keep exploding true true that is a
design for all the power just gonna tell
people that those are the terrorist
attacks so that our clients will still
buy the evil hawk thingy that grows
limbs out so you're sending out a
defective hazardous product before it's
been
yes you're like the EA of terrorists I
think so Ironman gets all these other
robotic iron men to come and help them
out
but mrs. Potts first of all what stark
catches her oh I told you I protect you
oh thank god except my hand is the pain
boy you are bad at this aren't you hey
come on I love you so much I had
completely pointless panic attacks let
me give me some credit they embedded
this so tommy circles out the guy
pearson is like hey my name is Tony
Stark
you killed my girlfriend prepare to die
don't look that angry you more know kind
of annoyed hey I had totally pointless
panic attacks for those like I'm Pierce
is being a crap out of Tony Stark but
then mrs. Potts is like my guy and
starches like mrs. Potts you sir right
no I can't give up on the notion that
you were gonna save me so I decided to
save myself oh well can you at least let
me have the finishing blue know your ear
and you never learn from your mistakes
oh that's a very cool way to finish him
all the movies are about me now what
we're sure that you wear this suit I
kick ass I'm emotionally responsible I
make better choices I'm up a jillion
times a better role model than you but
I'm the tech guy in an asshole that's
why you'll be my plainy sidekick what
I'm much more compelling story arcs than
you really need one thing you've learned
in this movie I drive cool cars
hey Iron Man 3 so Iron Man 3 was great
except for the fact that Iron Man is
both the most brilliant and dumbest
person in the world
it's like me giving away my address to
perfect strangers by saying it's the
Lucky Charms box on 33rd Street please
don't do anything with that information
I know general mail
Oh naughty with the toy inside
you